welcome to this video playing some book
from the you came and what do we get
yeah maybe don't want to play the
sameish all the time maybe Knight f3 it
sometimes in fact leads to comparable
positions with Bishop g5 92 later f3
okay now is going for c5 and probably
will get this g3 line queen a 5 that's
uncommon yeah the question is do I need
to maybe I can just play Bishop g2 check
check yeah this is not really great I
thank you for black looks looks very
loose and I'm very well developed
thought rook see one actually but this
is this is a bit much two points I mean
I already have sacrificed to pause but
Bishop f4 me
with bishop d6 in mind yeah white has
very nice compensation if it is enough
for two pawns I didn't need to sacrifice
on c3 as simply Bishop t2 was also
totally sufficient maybe this was was
better then they keep it simple approach
well do I want to take not really and
Bishop d6
the problem is after taking b.tech c6
he's got a quick Bishop a six and then
can free us bad bishop on c8 and I don't
have no beef I've what I really am
should have to to justify to justify the
whole thing yeah this is probably not
enough for two pawns now I should have
played them the keep it simple they keep
it simple approach may be here on b6
that's 93 it's a bit bit problematic be
693 well it's still not easy for black
to play but objectively is objectively
speaking I shouldn't have enough for two
pawns maybe yeah I was just about to
suggest this maybe this is an idea after
Bishop see seven years to retreated will
be eight probably so I have no way to to
attack the Queen and any meaningful way
I can't play 93 but it's not it's not
doing that much
hmm yeah it's not easy to make any
progress weapon if I've still a movie
I'm hard to save be five Bishop g5 at
least them maybe get something against
the center gym next time I play it
simple
after Queen a five Bishop g2 widest
widest simply in good shape sometimes
you really want to make it them
sometimes you want to play too
sophisticated where it is totally I'm
totally uncalled for in this case Bishop
e2 was just much better for wild jam
this is basically two pawns form not
much very very slight pressure
queen bee three in between a 4h from or
something okay yeah can take I can try
to take be seven now queen bee seven
Roxy form or take f6 first I don't know
maybe just take your first queen bee to
our queen queen bee 296 I've got to
Queen a 6 or i can just take it I can
take SMS even better 92 rookie one
should also be okay okay so just to a
five maybe attending attending 96 if it
takes it I well my compensation gets a
tool to get to agree that this may be
sufficient now maybe this is already
sufficient time unless I'm overlooking
some tactic which is always possible of
course might be fair look before or
something what happens after look before
you could have played with before I
think
now the term it's getting more and more
get much more play here for for my stuff
now I've got both bounce back
meditate at exxon g5 maybe on the one
hmm do I need to take it on I can also
play Bishop Bishop here time morning I
Scott nah he's got Queen d2 though 22
maybe rook 7c to playing on this week
back rank maybe you can take it I can
take maybe 70 no I can take CA sorry I
can take CH first and take it 7 m and
here hmm I thought rook 72 would be
would be cute playing on this week back
rank check while we look that one check
yeah I have this check fortunately yeah
so that I'm not not losing straight away
wait let's got rooked g1 ham maybe this
one look everyone Quincy ahead check
check hmm i don't know it's just wrong
check I cannot play for win here i can
check check green no I probably am
probably must take the draw yeah this
was a it was a bad game probably with
lots of lots of mistakes made by both
sides I mean the first mistake is great
Queen a5 is just not not really any good
i think i can just play this one
and this is a simple and good move
threatening a three it probably has to
take on deform and I don't really think
that Queen a five and be sure before is
this says this very well how nice and
harmonizes the word are coordinated
let's say yeah this is probably
interesting but if it is sufficient I
don't know maybe I should take here c5
to make sure i'm only one pawn down but
this is this is probably too much yeah
this is this is too much I simply don't
have enough compensation here i have a
very slight compensation but it's too
torn it's not one point ID I'm just two
bonds down it has fizzled out yeah and
this is probably not working here the
point is he miss look before I look
before wins instantly just just an
instant when I have no reply just losing
tons of material and after that I was
back in the game really yeah it gets it
gets very murky and this is this is lu
shang check exactly because he plays
what is what is sir the problem here can
play here we also has Masha page 3 of
course I am totally you've totally
busted of course yeah Queen moves
somewhere and then this one is sisters
winning yeah here I'm still lost rugby
too is winning but he had no time Jim
yeah Lucas e2 was losing is winning for
black jack and here i am very luckily
got the drawing yeah this was some less
than convincing i hope you still enjoyed
this blunder faster thanks for watching